noël messieurs bonsoir le programme
concorde continuer mais tout de même on
peut dire que le coup est dur hier soir
les deux grandes compagnies aériennes
américaine panam était w a annoncé en
effet qu'elle renonçait aux options
qu'elle avait prise sur l'avion
supersonique franco-britannique cela
représentait cet appareil pour la panam
et 6 pour la tête w il avant cette
décision a provoqué une certaine émotion
à paris à londres
d'autant que ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'une compagnie étrangère renonce
ainsi à utiliser concorde et que par
ailleurs entre crainte que d'autres
transporteurs américains adoptent la
même attitude
or il ne faut pas oublier que près de 60
mille salariés français britanniques
participent à la construction de
l'appareil c'est une partie dont l'enjeu
est gros puisque le programme concorde
représente 14 milliards de francs
actuels concorde cet état paris c'est
devenu un poker un pari technique tout
d'abord il est gagné un pari commercial
maintenant c'est le plus difficile
jusqu'à présent les grandes compagnies
aériennes américaines avaient misé sur
concorde mais aujourd'hui et il faut
bien insister sur sept aujourd'hui car
la situation peut évoluer dans la tenir
et c'est bien tout l'enjeu de la
bataille actuelle
aujourd'hui elle joue contre mais les
constructeurs relance la partie en
décidant concorde continue alors c'est
la partie de poker
chacun s'engage davantage pour faire
céder l'autre voyons les partenaires en
présence d'abord les utilisateurs paname
twh contre air france bo a c'est tout
tbw à 2 millions 600 mille passagers par
an 15 millions si l'on tient compte de
son important réseau intérieur paname 13
millions 400 mille passagers en 1972 un
réseau de 145 1000 km
c'est le premier transporteur aérien des
lignes internationales ses deux
compagnons toujours tenu un rôle
primordial au sein de l'aviation
mondiale et leur choix de matériel a
toujours servi d'exemple mais depuis
quelques années l'âge d'or du transport
aérien est terminée la crise générale
qu'il traverse
la mise en service trop hâtive d'avion
géant qu'il s'est révélé difficile de
remplir la lutte de trafic enfin sur le
marché de l'atlantique nord ont provoqué
un déficit croissant de leur trésorerie
tbw a su se redresser de justesse paname
pour sa part affiche à présent aider
ici de 150 millions de dollars qu'elle a
accumulés ces quatre dernières années
aujourd'hui le problème qui se pose est
le suivant leur décision négative
at-elle en entraîner d'autres car les
compagnies américaines ont été
catégoriques
si même nous n'avions pas de difficultés
financières nous n'aurions pas commander
concorde
parce qu'il n'est pas rentable pourtant
les dirigeants d'air france sont
parvenus à des conclusions inverses nous
le rentabiliseront en essayant de le
commercialiser d'une manière aussi
original que possible et en fournissant
aussi bien un service au sol
kabore tout à fait exceptionnel c'est à
dire que vous comptez aménager des
services de taxi ou de trains spéciaux
qui amènerait les voyageurs directement
l'avion et ses rares ce sont les études
que nous faisons actuellement est allé
presque comptons faire c'est offrir un
produit tout à fait nouveau et très
attractif le service concorde cécile à
risque encore combien faut-il de
passagers dans un concorde pour que le
vol soit rentable
oh ça dépend des ling et ça dépend de l'
influence du concorde sur les autres
lignes de la compagnie ou les autres
avions mais aux environs de 65% nous
pensons que nous pourrions commencer à
être dans de bonnes conditions de
rentabilité
voilà donc le point de vue des
utilisateurs qui sont donc divisés sur
le problème de la rentabilité de l'avion
on peut évidemment se poser beaucoup de
questions concorde qu'il était bien
conçue pour les besoins précis de cette
époque et surtout quel est l'avenir de
l'appareil franco-britannique si le
marché américain doit se refermer
faut-il par exemple envisager une
évolution de ce programme laventure
concorde n'est pas terminée et elle est
déjà commencée il ya onze ans